any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
a friend a sort of superhero in some
sense although I'm gonna I'm gonna try
to challenge you in a couple of things
in your theories and your politics and
so forth today I hope we'll have a
wide-ranging conversation but Eric
Weinstein pleasure to welcome you on to
the into the impossible podcast Brian
it's a total pleasure to be here and I
appreciate your strategy and build them
up first for an initial dopamine hit and
then tear them down later during the
remainder of the podcast that's right
well I always say you know I got that
from your mother and if you want I can
get it from your mother-in-law how to
introduce you but either way I think I
think you're in good shape
so I had on my I had on my podcast a
couple of weeks ago now a certain
mathematician and that mathematician
generated some controversy as they would
say in his homeland and I wanted to say
that the mathematicians last name is
begins with a w I won't say who it is
but I want you to sort of a pine on this
and let me know your feelings how you
would react to it if the W stood for
let's just say Weinstein so it said
mathematician W it has been said about
his theory is that it's not clear what
his goals are he says he wants the
intention and feedback of the physics
community but his unconventional
approach soliciting public comments on
exceedingly long any results from
perhaps long ago almost indoors and
shallot remain obscure mathematician W
says he wants physicists respect the
ones consulted said gaining it would
require him to recognize and engage with
the prior work of others in the
scientific community so this is not
written about Weinstein just spoiler
alert it's written about somebody else
another person I have great respect for
but but I'm a mathematician who is not a
mathematician right yeah so what do you
think about this is this something that
that you can abide by or what's your
feeling on those sort of sentiment
expressed by the author in this in this
quote well this is a very difficult
question and a very interesting one what
I've been opining on recently is is that
we have two communities that are
behaving very strange and
one community is central to the
institutional world of science the other
is outside of that war now traditionally
in very difficult fields like physics we
assume that people who are working
outside of an institutional framework
are pranks and their reasons that that
has been a good general bet I think that
you'd have to say that it has almost
always been correct at least with
respect to fundamental physics but we've
developed a new problem which is you'd
like to say that many of the core
research programs currently let's say at
the heart of theoretical physics our
fringe but how can you call something
fringe if it's at the center of
respectability
because fringe means two things one it
means peripheral which these things
cannot be because they may lie at the
heart of our institutional science and
our institutional sense making
but wacky yes they are so when you have
a wacky Center
and you have a whacky fringe you need
different language and so I've come up
with the the term narc or the wacky
Center which is crank spelled backwards
so right now the problem that you have
is you have a very difficult situation
the language is too impoverished to
capture what is going on most of the
people who are wacky at the center of
theoretical physics
our competence that is if the field
suddenly knew what it was doing again
and when I say theoretical physics
there's just one stupid gotcha we have
to get through I mean fundamental
physics I mean the kind of physics that
you go to bookstores to read about to
fill your soul with with wonder and
right and that's a topic of this latest
physicist who starts with the W his
project I mean Stephen Wolfram direct
figured it out skadoosh so the the
situation is that I think that if the
Institute for Advanced Study were to get
their hands on the next great thing they
would instantly go back to being regular
style physicist and I'm not positive
that most of the crank community would
do that mmm in some sense what's gone on
in the center is that you have
physicists who are like generals who
haven't fought a war in forever but have
been playing war games and have
increasingly come to believe that the
war games that they're playing is
actually the business heat general you
know a soldier a sergeant and in fact
what they've been doing is playing with
toy theories that don't seem to really
have to do what they're supposed to be
doing so nobody knows what to do with
this circumstance and having the old war
about whether or not it is better to be
respectable an incremental vs. wild
wiggy out there and and to take the hit
to one's reputation that seems like a
very poor choice of activities which
just to spend our energy he built
problem which is that since the 1970s we
haven't had theory led breakthroughs in
fundamental physics that would take
anyone to Stockholm as a crude measure
and we talked about the worth of the
Nobel Prize but was distracted this is a
yeah although he knows nobody knows what
to do the fact that we're coming up on
50 years of being lost in the wilderness
in some sense and some people choose to
deny it they say supersymmetry guts
and strings m-theory loop quantum
gravity are all promising one should
just calibrate one's expectations other
people are saying what the hell are you
talking about we've never been in
situation this dire so I do want to push
back to slightly on that Eric because I
did consult with a friend who is who is
a colleague here at UCSD for just a
partial list if this was done in
response to Peter White who I know is a
friend of yours and Sabine Haas and
father they're kind of claims again
similar to what you're saying in the
lack of the dearth of progress in the
last you know let's call it for decades
and here's an incomplete list that I got
back when I asked you know what are some
of the theoretical led driven
fundamental physics breakthroughs here's
a list incomplete list thermodynamics of
information quantum computing inflation
conformal field theory in two dimensions
conformal field theory in greater than
two dimensions modern effective field
theory heavy quarks binary black holes
super conductivity and then a cosmology
again we can we can sort of debate I
don't I don't even think these are the
most impressive things necessarily I
would that the theory of the determinant
line bundle in the Quillen connection
geometric quantization the rigorous
founding of quantum field theory around
issues of enhanced board ISM now I
didn't think that was a good list no so
it's not I don't mean to be rude but I'm
not trying to make this stupid kill shot
here against the community okay if the
community is fundamentally dishonest
it's a dishonest community now it lies
about its achievements it lies about its
failures so I think that what I'm doing
is I'm giving it its due I'm saying I
don't think guts are dead grand unified
theories I don't even think
supersymmetry is dead
I think that the field doesn't know how
to explain itself the field doesn't know
how to defend itself it lashes out at
anybody who dares to contradict the
official narrative and it's enough I
mean we were just all sick to death of
listening to David gross and Ed Witten
tell us what's what because we don't
believe them well I think there's this
you know and you've spoken about this
you have you know sort of a no-bail were
the level of pithy three-letter acronyms
some even more famous than others but
one of them that I do cotton to is this
idea of the gated institutional
narrative and I saw this on display and
you know again we can edit out anything
you don't like but but you know there
were people that as soon as you posted
your I think you know it was maybe
provocative to post it on April Fool's
Day but but nevertheless it was reacted
to with with great almost vitriol
bordering at least in some corners of
the Internet and almost like ad hominem
level attacks and I've experienced the
same thing when I interviewed Stephen
Wolfram and Eileen I asked people you
know do you not think these folks
deserve a voice I mean you cannot claim
that Stephen is not a brilliant mind you
may think he is arrogant or that he you
know tends to be self-promotional etc
etc and even people were criticizing me
for not asking him about his employee
relations and I said look I'm not 60
minutes I'm gonna interview him I'm
gonna be respectful as I always am I'm
gonna hear both sides and if you don't
like it you know I'll give you your
money back on the internet for the
subscription cost but I feel I want to
know and again we don't have to talk
about anything you don't feel like
talking about but I feel like this
narrative that is being proposed is sort
of part of this like the first reaction
which I think is a sign of sloppy
thinking is I'll believe it when it's
published now I've heard people say that
about the most extravagantly you know
hyperbolic claims I've heard people say
that about ordinary claims and it's sort
of become a canard Shibboleth and I
wonder how you feel about that I mean
after all we're treating peer-review as
if a it's sacrosanct handed down from
you know God or Mohammed
on the mountain or if you like that it's
been around in in science as a useful
vehicle of course it has utility and can
I'm utility but what do you make of the
veneration of peer review which which as
Stephen Wolfram has said in connection
to this he said I think it's corrupt
I think traditional route is a giant
story of somewhat corrupt gaming I think
it's some sort of inevitable that
happens with these very large systems
it's a pity and I point out you know
there wasn't peer review for Galileo
there wasn't peer review for much of
Newton wasn't peer review for Watson and
Crick in 1933
that's right so but now I also get a
similar level of you know criticism for
people that who do say legitimately well
you get a lot of emails from true cranks
and true people that are seeking
hyperbolic attention so how do you
manage the gated narrative with having
some value I always say the hardest
thing is for somebody to strike a middle
ground not to be polarized that's easy
to be polarized it's bogus if it's not
peer-reviewed it's corrupt if it is how
do you strike a middle ground is there
value in the middle girl well that's a
lot and these are important questions if
you really want to dig into it I'd be
game yeah please do alright so first of
all Stephen Wolfram is breaking the
rules and there's suspicion that he's
breaking the rules because he doesn't
have a theory of everything and he's
advertising it as if he does yep
using PR and he's using the weight of
his name in part to make a splash a lot
of people who feel that that is wrong to
do particularly as an individual take
exception to that and one can easily
understand why they would take exception
that because it's an end run around some
kind of quality okay so that is probably
true
the other thing is that it complicates
the life of a working physicist to hear
constantly you know my friends has an
uncle whose best friend thinks he solved
the theory of everything with it and he
has a perpetual motion machine to prove
it
like we will you come out to his house
and in Peoria and and check it out
nobody wants to lead a life like that
and I think that that's entirely
understandable so I think we have to
sort of first of all just demonstrate
that we're not confused about why people
would have this in a working world it
wouldn't it be great to have a nifty
little Shibboleth and discount
everything that came in so if all the
cranks you know used red crayon on
napkins and that's how they submit
everything then you have an idea of
who's a whack job and who's actually all
right now you have a different problem
which is that you've got whack jobs
inside of the leading institutions who
have been part of whack job programs and
the whack job programs have whack job
journalists inside of the whack job
leading papers so if I open up the
science times for years there were these
breathless stories about how m-theory
was going to give me better toast clean
my fingernails and give me the theory of
everything in short order what happened
to that well those are institutional
connects and the problem is that the
connects really disliked the cranks and
the cranks are trying to avoid the cars
now first of all you should know that I
am not aware of the vitriol that you're
talking about from the professional
community aimed at me I'm aware of it
towards stephen wolfram and i have been
told that there are certain reddit's
that got shut down very personal very
unpleasant and first of all you have to
remember that the field has a lot to be
embarrassed about I published essays in
edge dorg critical of the string em
Theory program particularly some of the
nastiest things they have every time
it's just it's so bad it is funny one of
the things I
I forget whether David whether Joe
polchinski maybe was credited with this
but there was the claim that if anybody
comes up with anything that isn't string
theory we'll just incorporate it into
the string theory program and say it is
so it's like oh wow is that how the
locals play great to know you know
there's this sort of when nobody's got a
theory of quantum gravity you have blue
quantum gravity and string theory vying
to be the leading non theory of non bond
gravity is another neither of them seem
to work yep all of this leads to
complete disarray and of course all the
people have to fight over is prestige
that's left over you know from the feast
that was served by Dirac and Einstein
and company Fineman and now their
descendants are chewing over the bones
that were thrown in the scrap heat and
it's pretty slim pickins so of course
people are going to be nasty I think
that you have to expect that they're
going to be nasty and I think that you
also have to be sympathetic which is
that if you're slaving away on a tiny
fragment of a long ago abandoned program
because that's what you did your
dissertation and you happen to have an
office somewhere in the dot e-d-u
ecosystem you're pretty pissed off that
a guy like Stephen Wolfram who might be
you know on a fooling around flying
private you know is hiring his own
Armada PR agent and creating a splash so
I think it's I think nd the invidious
nature of this the the palpable sense of
failure the sense that he doesn't really
have theory of everything etc this
animates people in it and it should
animate there are sensible questions
like why is it that people who come from
outside the community only work on the
theory of everything why don't they work
on adding a couple of extra digits of
precision to some QCD calculus right or
you know revisiting or trying to prove
Altman was wrong whatever I mean you
know it's always Einstein was wrong and
here's why I always feel like it's you
know it's like Dungeons & Dragons I
think they're gonna get you know
Einstein so funny he's like the one
thing that I really never want to do is
I want to damage Einstein I feel like
we're so blessed that he came through
this way like trying to go after him
because you want to seems really
perverse so let's get into you know your
approach to I want to make sure that we
can't we settle that the people are
gonna focus on on this segment if they
focus on this at all I've built a fairly
large platform from talking about things
other than physics predominant and I'm
not a physicist you know people always
say physicists area twice and they
almost always correct them to be really
quite good about saying hey I'm not part
of your professional game I'm not taking
your professional resources I'm not
dirty pristine archive pep-pep th you
know preprint server and they're still
pissed off
they're still angry and they're hanging
because of hubris you know the it takes
a ridiculous sense of self-possession
and delusion to think that you're gonna
make progress in the field that is
probably the hardest field of human
endeavor that's been stuck for the
longest time on the hardest problem so
I'm weirdly sympathetic to these mom's
errs I don't know what you want to call
them there they're very pleasant people
I wish that they would you know I don't
know weave is legal they should probably
smoke a joint and chill out and and
actually think about whether this really
represents where they want to be in
their lives
shouting at people after such a dearth
of results for decades well you know my
tagline is always you know I love
astronomy I love physics cuz it's not
like in astronomy there's a Republican
constellation over there and there's a
Democratic comment over there it should
be like a political political free zone
and not necessarily a safe space where
you know ideas can't be challenged and
and you know part of what I respect
about people like you like will
is that you're willing to come on you
know I'm not a pushover to just accept
everything that he or you would have to
say and yet I like it's extremely
valuable and I'm not just saying I would
say this about anybody who's of course
you have to get over some gate to use
the Weinstein Ian expression but at the
same time because there's only so much
time in the day let's be honest I only
have so much time to do the actual work
I get paid to do by the state of
California and and also explore other
things and do other projects I think a
there is a jealousy there is a sense of
jealousy but B I do think there is
validity to people that say look these
these people are bypassing our
traditional time-tested modalities of
going at an attacking scientific
scientific nature and and then this guy
who's very eloquent and very deep goes
on Joe Rogan and he just blasts away and
he'll get more attention you know than
the exponent of my H index and I I think
that that there is a balance there I can
take issue with that if you don't yeah
let's go for it let's talk at the
h-index by the lake originates here at
UCSD by my colleague Jorge Hirsch and I
tease him about that because his highest
cited paper is actually about the
h-index and I hope to have him on the
podcast at some times talked about
attribution and credit first of all one
of the things that's interesting about
the h-index if you think about it maybe
you could apply it to Kurt girdle or
somebody who published them nothing
right exactly
right and so I I partially have an
aspiration if I'm going to have any
impact on physics whatsoever
god willing I would love to do it with
like an H index of zero or undefined in
order to destroy the H index because
it's a proxy and people get very carried
away with showing you how much hard work
they've done in the cargo cult the in
general is non-productive
so it's a pretty bad proxy when it
becomes circular with respect to joe
rogan first of all your community has a
huge problem I can't tell you how bored
most of us are hearing about the
multiverse or many world or entanglement
we're going to talk about all those by
the way they got double slit experiment
it's not not interesting it's not that
they're not fascinating in fact that
they're not confusing and perplexing and
deep and all these things but we've
heard it 12,000 times before and whether
Sean Carroll has a new wrinkle on the
multiverse or not is irrelevant the part
of the problem is that you guys haven't
even pushed out the Dirac equation
people know who Dirac is they don't
really know how to spell the word
spinner they they don't understand the
hopf fibration can be visualized so with
all due respect to the community you
failed you guys are just you're terrible
and when I think there's something sexy
actually I want to when I go on Joe
Rogan and I push out the hopf fibration
even if I don't explain it if I just
show people here is a principle fiber
but this is the kind of object on which
gauge see please take I've got artists
all over the world trying to depict the
basic structure so that people can see
rather than Lawrence Krauss going on Joe
Rogan and giving some analogy that is
supposed to be about what gauge theory
is I'm trying to go on Joe Rogan and say
look you know you know the Penrose
stares repair cases but what if that is
actually the depiction of horizontal
subspace is defining a connection in
some sense in what you're looking at is
Halle know I'm starting to get the right
words into the hands of dangerous
children of the Internet who may not
have access access to Princeton Stanford
or Harvard or MIT or Oxford or Cambridge
yeah so no I think that is valuable and
so okay but like with a little bit of
self-righteous self education match me
instead of coming on in one more time
telling me the same sort of mind-numbing
stuff particle seems to go through both
slits no it's a way damn it can you
please just explain this thing properly
you just get to the point where you're
talking about you know hermitian
operators and eigenvectors and
eigenvalues rather than this mumbo-jumbo
speak and if you don't mind yes I'm
going to show them pictures they've no
seen before that you should have been
showing them and so the fact that you
didn't do your job don't come after me
blaming me
enjoy me beat me yeah I think that
that's some of the most valuable service
I know it's not necessarily intentional
and maybe it is I mean knowing you it
could be intentional that controversy
sheds sometimes too much heat but it
does bring light to these obscure topics
and other guests that I've had on and
you know Joe always takes you know the
best of my guests so he's yeah I've had
on Sean Carroll I've had on you know
Stephen Wolfram and I've had on Roger
Penrose and I know you've had on him as
well and he's another person and it's
like you know what do you have to say
about him of course he he doesn't go on
Joe Rogan for at a guy's 82 or something
years old he's not going there to
bolster his social you know his social
heads he's going on because he's
passionately curious about extrapolating
from the ivory tower where we both
inhabit although I believe less so in
the case of an experimentalist so I do
want to get to that but he's you know
bringing too lot to mind these same
concept Escher's you know in infinite
hyperbolic space projection things that
yeah what if there is some young kid who
instead of being who had let's just say
she can have the choice she can look at
the double slit experiment that's
wonderful but yeah what about looking at
projective you know spaces what about
these conformal transformations I think
there is and that he was the first
science writer that I ever read popular
science writer as a 17 or 18 year old I
didn't understand much what he was
saying and if there was a Joe Rogan back
then maybe it would have turned me on
even more and maybe I would have you
know had a better career as a theorist
although I doubt it maybe but you know I
guess what might might take is gonna be
is if I'm talking about the Wuyang
dictionary and most physicists don't
even think about the yang dictionary and
these are the pivotal moments in your
life you know I'm not taking a ton of
flack for saying wrong things and then
he'll say well that wasn't a complete
explanation well no kidding you know my
last one went out too I think it's now
at 6.1 million people I mean even for
Joe Rogan that's pretty large yeah
principal bundles out at scale so that
I'm accosted in airports with people
saying I didn't understand there's
there's a there's a you one vibration
and an S you fibration I
you're damn straight I'm doing your PR
for you you guys can't even figure out
how to get enough dollars into your
field to keep you guys solvent and
despite the fact that I'm huge critic
I'm a huge critic of how you guys run
your shop you don't mind I'm going to
try to get you some funding some
visibility and I'd appreciate it to shut
up yeah I think there is a lot of
validity to that Eric I feel the same
way about Wolfram and it'll be
interesting to get your have Wolfram on
your show at some point because I think
you know these or maybe I could host
both of you at the same time because I
think there is a value in and I see a
parallel between what he does and what
you do and in your life mission at least
in the geometric unity project and it
comes down to you know kind of this
classic description of what you know I
think Einstein or somebody else used to
say is like wood and marble you know the
kind of operational quantized
you know computational world of physics
and the pure geometric you know
irreducible fundamentals the wooden
marble the wood is is the stress energy
tensor yes but I would say actually it's
steel because it should be man-made or
human-made right it shouldn't be me wood
is met as naturally occurring and
marbles naturally I don't speak German
that the original quote is in German and
I think it's cheap wood and sometimes
it's even translated as balsa cults I
think as it is right my concern is is
that the real problem of course is in
the marble mmm boom that the problem is
in the wood yeah so let's let's turn to
that now just today I heard a wonderful
read a wonderful piece not that I agree
with it necessarily but in quantum
magazine which is doing wonderful kind
of popularization of very complex
mathematical and technical you know
cosmological etc the hottest topics sort
of in the field and has great writers to
boot and there's a piece today that says
what goes on inside of a proton the
quark math is still in conflict with
experiments and they go through and they
show you know it's beautiful animations
of a quark gluon plasma and they talk
about this million-dollar math prize
awaits anyone who can solve this type of
equation using QCD to show how massive
entities like protons form and I'm
thinking like what percentage of people
are going to understand it even in the
physics community as you point out I'm
affording the map
the mask yeah right luckily for me I had
Robert brandenburger and Jerry Guralnik
as you know cosmology and group theory
teachers and I learned a great deal from
them and for my colleague Stephon
Alexander I mean your mutual friend who
is incredibly creative and productive
otherwise I wouldn't have learned about
it I mean I can go I went basically my
whole education without being required
to learn about group theory and arguably
does it come into play when I'm building
a microwave radiometer for use at 17,000
feet above sea level no it doesn't but
on the same time it's the reason I got
into physics in the first place yeah and
so what I want to kind of just toss her
in with you is on the experimental side
because I think we see things you know
hammer theory we see everything like
it's our own personal hammer you're
obviously coming mathematically but it
gives you great visibility into you know
I always say like if I go like this you
know I have a problem but I don't know I
have a problem I'm covering my eye for
people that are listening on the on the
audio version of the podcast and I think
getting a perspective from outside there
are things that really hit a nerve when
we talk about things especially things
that maybe untestable and and for
example the multiverse I personally have
a lot of issues with the multi-verse and
I know people celebrate I actually a
Sean Carroll this is rich you have a lot
of issue yeah exactly right I asked Sean
Carroll you know what would you say is
the you know is the likelihood that the
multiverse is true and he said 50% and I
asked him more what's the likelihood
that God has she said less than 1% you
wouldn't say zero he he certainly you
know very very knowledgeable about how
to ascribe his priors but on the other
hand I think yes when you get into these
descriptions of course it's not and I
don't want to go through geometric unity
except to ask you if we can post a the
PowerPoint in the show notes that you
showed after your April Fool's Day
podcast because I think you know people
are leaping and saying well you know
2013 you promise there is an archive
paper coming and you know I look for it
I don't see it but would it be possible
to post a PowerPoint that you use just
if for the people because I don't want
to go through it you've gone through it
with Joe you've gone through with Lex
Friedman first of all I mean
you can screenshot the PowerPoint I can
come up with a PowerPoint I get very
innovative by this talk hmm communities
really badly behaved and my feeling is
that you don't really I don't think you
really care that much about the
PowerPoint most people in the community
who have this kind of like paper or
didn't happen is kind of attitude
this is shorthand for please just just
say lagrangians we can go through it and
invalidate you you know that's really
the energy the gain of institutional
bloggers on Jim well know the point
being that a Lagrangian is a very clear
and clean way of saying what a theory is
there's a fascination in the community
which is well if you think you got this
whole thing why don't you put you pen
down tell us what it is and like I'm not
even that necessarily that's scared of
that that's not the issue the issue is
you guys just aren't honest about where
you're really at your irritated you're
pissed off and you're pissed off
partially it mean but you pissed off
largely at yourselves and everybody
knows it and one of the reasons that I
you know I don't have a ton of fear is
is that I don't have you know somebody
else regulating my oxygen in the
community so the issue of what a theory
is how to how to milk it for information
a lot of this was dealt with very well
in direct 1963 Scientific American
article
deserves to be very widely read even
though our audience he somewhat used
Schrodinger as his stalking horse where
he talked about Schrodinger's failure to
agree with with experiment and the issue
is that apparently the Schrodinger
hadn't taken to consideration certain
aspects of spins this has to do with
what I would call the suit maker and the
tailor if you have a a kind of a weird
way of paying for things where like
whoever discovers the island doesn't get
the island named after them but whoever
climbs to the top of the highest summit
on the island and put
flag there that's the name of the island
so the guy who's spending his time tying
up the boat at the dock you know gets
gets eaten by the guy who races to the
Sun okay well that's a pretty
innervating thing or like you pay for
the last leg of the relay different than
who did the best time in the relay race
you saw this with for example the Ponk
array conjecture in mathematics where
somebody's building on several large
steps but it's you know crowman solution
to the injection so you've got all these
sort of issues of the political economy
of physics and mathematics and you know
this is what causes people to get really
pissed off because de rocks point was
Schrodinger came up with the suit but
until the tailoring is done you don't
know where it fits the patient which is
experiment or you know that the client
and so this is sort of the problem which
is why do you want to deliver a suit to
somebody's gonna claim the tailor made
the suit when he did the last alteration
and I think that this is part of the
problem with popper leave least the
naive application of popper and people
have to realize there's a price for
playing all of these incredibly
innervating games with credit and
pretending that nobody cares about
credit and then everybody behind the
state scenes that's each other outside
of the system I've never seen such a
group of completely hypocritical people
who all seem to only want to serve
nature God Jesus but on the other hand
what they really seem to do is behind
the scenes demand that they get proper
credit proper citations you know and
just another another quick point when
one maldacena one his breakthrough prize
he had to explain what he'd been up to
he was talking about gauge theory and he
had to illustrate it and he chose to
illustrate it with the economics of
exchange rates which actually came out
of work that my wife did at Harvard
right it happened that he didn't credit
my wife's dissertation when some of this
work appeared he knew about the you know
when I when I ran into him in San
Francisco he changed that he also
diluted us a little bit by quoting some
irrelevant work
so you know my feeling about this is the
community also has a huge problem not
acknowledging people that it doesn't
think are going to show up at the next
conference you sort of know who all the
regulars are and you play with them
using the game theory
so yeah you would attribute outside of
the community very often the citation
games don't work the credit games don't
work because we don't have a credible
threat and one of the nice things about
having a relatively large test and
access to some of the largest platforms
in the world is the community hasn't
really quite figured out that you're not
necessarily going to see me at your
conference if you don't invite me but if
you don't credit my work and and and you
start to you know talk about it you are
going to have a problem with repeated
games yeah different game works best
when you have repeated games and part of
the problem with why people take on
cranky affectations when they don't
start off as pranks is that they come to
understand that the system doesn't work
as advertised but if you get into the
substance of what these theories are
that would be fun to not just talking
around them but talking about yeah I do
want to talk about that but just to
circle back you know I mean you it seems
to be common for you know one of two
different approaches you can attribute
malice or incompetence now it's hard to
believe that you know one would be
incompetent is he is brilliant so I
guess you know if that's your only
alternative to attribute something
malicious that is you know that that's
certainly your right it's it's a it's a
behavior pet I loved Isadora singer
who's been a dear friend Martin in the
past but he would forget when he heard
something from me because I wasn't have
properly in the right place in his
consciousness we see this with women
very often in meetings where they'll say
something five minutes later a man will
say more or less the same thing and
everybody will say Oh Jim's done it
again right all this keep eating right
there's something called the Matthew
effect you hit tilde effect right yeah
and then there's the Matilda effect
so all of these things have to do with
the way in which our social brains
compute how we wish to be diluted going
forward who wish to acknowledge and we
make an implicit calculation am I likely
to see this Princeton tomorrow or not
right yeah I do look at it I'm just here
to remind people it's the up more
expensive mm-hmm
certainly it is true that that you have
a prominence which i think is
unquestionably earned that you've you
have developed a personality and and own
unique modality of thinking you're also
incredibly courageous which is one of
the rarest of all traits I don't think
you really give a figure I'll say
because it's a it's a PG conversation on
the other hand you know I look at I look
at you and I see these kind of a
different image of a lot of my
colleagues who are very dear they kind
of remind me of these you know fiddler
crabs that you see at the beach here in
San Diego you know they're incredibly
well-developed on one side of their of
theirs of their shell and the other side
is this puny little digit and but you
don't see them going around you know and
kind of like berating the the other
crabs that have two equally sized you
know protuberances or whatever you call
claws and and that it's kind of it's
puzzling to me because you see it for
people like neil degrasse tyson who is
not you know an active scientist or bill
nye who is an engineer by training and
and their outstanding communicators and
yet there are some of the largest
targets of jealousy it's just it's just
seems strange it's like me criticizing
the conductor of an orchestra for being
you know getting attention during this
let me take my my opponents view yeah as
steel managed slightly yeah it in part
has to do how much deference the
fairness these people give to the
community that they are implicitly
mining so I think everybody knows that
they in some sense benefit from neil
degrasse tyson's popularity you know
Brian Greene is potentially kind of a
more interesting version of this because
got great comic timing huh boy that guy
would have been fantastic in vaudeville
and he's a straight up but a geometric
gangster you know he can hang with the
best of them I think the
in the case of Bill Nye this the sort of
the sense is how did a guy with a bowtie
come to speak for the rest of us who are
doing research and so I think there's
there are healthy tension I think one of
the points that I keep trying to make is
I'm not speaking for the community as
their voice like I may be pissed but I
also think you know I think I've been
very clear that theoretical physics
community is the intellectual version of
SEAL Team six and our underfunding of
theoretical physics is a tragedy it's in
part what causes the community to be
unspeakably beastly to to not only each
other but Outsiders right fighting over
the crimes of the scrums of this cookie
that's shriveling up well you guys need
more money you've struck the world's
worst licensing deal somebody's got to
defend the theoretical physics community
because you're not allowed to license
what you've contributed to the world and
therefore you can't you know if
everybody had to pay for every
semiconductor instruction or every URL
every email ever sent or every every all
the protection that came from the
hydrogen bombs and lives that were saved
to America by being able to end the
world whatever it is it's enormous
its enormous the theoretical physics
community should never have to beg for
another die but I should the ought from
is though Eric how do you actually what
are gonna we're gonna play just wait
you call them taxpayer dollars I'm not a
physicist those are the dollars for the
most part the extent to which the modern
economy is built on physics whether it's
communications or computation or or
protection or chemistry or whatever
let's be clear there physics dollars and
we had a licensing deal and you guys
Welch you the general public welts the
taxpayer Welch don't bog bug me about
your taxpayer dollars you guys are the
beneficiaries the best deal in history
shut up
fund the theoretical physics community
yes they're horrible yes they're failing
he not doing their job yes they're lying
to you start paying them they will be
much better they'll still not be perfect
they're arrogant because the reason for
the arrogance I don't hear any
not saying anything remotely like what
I'm saying and I try to be fair just
like with Juan yeah well I sold up our
differences I'm not saying that I'm
pissed at him I am saying that it's a
very common behavior pattern I've had
the same issue with John Baez over the
octone Ian's you know again I can settle
my differences but I'm just telling you
that from the outside it's very strange
that when I go to a gathering I come in
as a Harvard ph.d I'm treated one way
come into the employee of Peter teal I'm
treated as the dumb money it has to be
convinced that we should throw it at the
community because unity is doing the
most mind-blowing stuff of all time when
I start talking technically you see
people have that that's feeling like wow
you're not supposed to be able to do
that right then you go through this
phase transition and break out the hopf
fibration I want to ask you does this
not result naturally as the evolutionary
culmination of the what I call the
academic Hunger Games I mean you start
off and get into the best college you
need to do all sorts of activities and
get good grades and take good tests and
and so forth then you go to college and
you're competing in the physical
sciences and let's say you're gonna be a
theoretical physicist you're competing
with some of the brightest minds who
have ever lived in your peer group
you got to outlast them to get a good
good PhD slot then you got a shine as a
PhD student get the attention of your
advisor then you got to get a good
letter recommendation and a job offer
for a prestigious post then you got to
get a good it's just a minor it's gotten
so much worse since 20 years ago when I
went through the final rung in this
ladder and then 10 yeah go ahead
we've to stop this this is how do you
stop it how do you how do you undo a
thousand-year-old
tradition this is not a
thousand-year-old tradition this has to
do with the end of our Bush the endless
frontier the expansion of the
post-secondary education system you know
I was I was hanging out with the Provost
at UCSD and he didn't even understand
the effect of the aisle Burke amendment
of 1976 by by Dole in 1980 he fraudulent
NSF and Naas projections of a looming
shortage that opened the floodgates
foreign labor universities that Mis
classification is student apparent
there's an entire recent horrible
history of turning the modern professor
into a serf not just the graduate
student into a surf but attempt to
destroy academic freedom if you cannot
tell people to screw off and know that
you are still funded the next day you
can still come into your office the
field is lost yeah but I mean there's so
I did want to talk about let's just go
there now academic freedom is it still
valuable as it's still necessary I make
the claim that in my field in
experimental physics until Kovan 19
which I do want to pick your brains on
until Kovan 19 I had a hundred percent
employment rate for all my PhDs and my
undergraduates is 14 people as of
yesterday have become a PhD they've gone
out to professorships prestigious
postdocs and and so forth so there's
there's no gating up until that point
it's certainly a seller's market you
know job seekers market up until this
level I don't know exactly in the same
sense for in the theoretical market
although I have very many friends but
they take fewer students and so it's a
little bit normalized in that sense but
in terms of academia and freedom I mean
I could say whatever I want but I can
also even if I didn't have tenure I
could say you know I could say whatever
I want also and go and get a job in
industry or go and get a job in the
finance nah that's not to diminish it
Eric sorry just lots of diminish it but
just saying that I have a valuable set
of Liam Neeson like skills that I convey
to my students that are very flexible
and and I I know that's true of
theorists as well so to what extent is a
professor of physics need to be tenured
and guaranteed fiefdom for life arguing
against my own interest but you know or
eat let's go so sorry
yeah go ahead it's very important this
is the replacement of F human and it's
not just about whether you have a job
there's all sorts of ways to turn up the
heat on a professor you can put them in
a shitty office you can give them a huge
teaching load you can humiliate them
there are all sorts of ways to fire
people who can't be hired so
there's an old joke unfortunately I've
lived long enough that it's no longer
relevant which is what's the difference
between free speech under the Soviet and
American Constitution and the answer is
is that the Soviet Constitution gives
you the right to say anything in protest
your government but the American
Constitution guarantees your freedom the
day after so the key question is can you
tell your field to screw off and still
get grants that's a question right can
you tell I'm the part can you tell your
department chair that they're out of
line trying to force you to sign a
diversity and inclusion of which you
should you know tremble reverently with
your pen in hand to sign know that when
you don't sign you're gonna be fine so I
think that partially the problem is also
you cannot say that giving academic
freedom to people who will never use it
if you if you over vet you make sure
that the people who get academic freedom
are the people you can trust never to
need it yeah that all of these things
don't work the key issue is you need
dangerous safe people dangerous might by
virtue of the fact that they can say
everything that needs to be said safe
and that they're not going to abuse it
to say things that shouldn't and even he
said and if you can't have dangerous
safe people knowing that they're going
to be fine the day after they said what
needed to be said pissed everybody off
but woke everybody up and it's not
academic free do you really feel like
that could happen if I criticize and
when am I gonna get my tenure [ __ ] for
my teaching assignment at UCSD you know
greatly enhanced punished in that way
well I'm not saying that there's a
direct transmission mechanism I didn't
know that you and Ed Witten were in the
same game but I say that Ed Witten is
perhaps the finest you know
mathematician of our time
but that his leadership of the
theoretical physics has been arguably
disastrous and that he earned
effectively as a geometers and spent as
a string theorist
that's a very dangerous statement if I
was in fact at let's say the center for
theoretical physics at MIT and you know
I feel about ed Witten the way people
sometimes feel about Voldemort which is
they want to be very careful even saying
his name at this advanced age of my life
he's one of the few people that I find
absolutely terrifying and that's not
politically just intellectually the
neurons on that guy just I've never seen
anything like it I mean just just
recently he he came up with a way to
test for a black hole in the outer solar
system so now he is venturing into my
turf he's he's gotten into astrophysics
so I could be I could you know
theoretically be endangered I suppose
well but I'm just trying to say that
part of the problem was I didn't care
people's dr. David gross David gross who
again you know fabulous physicist and
one really that the the seminal figure
to cross over from the you know last
major improvements in the standard model
into the world of strings and beyond you
know he gave these talks year after year
to sort of say where the theoretical
physics community was going and there
wasn't enough ability to say are we
going over a cliff
is this a kisses crazy is this insane I
mean what are we doing people like that
voice was silenced because people were
terrified I would hear people say oh I'm
so glad you said something but I could
never say so and I really dislike them
mm-hmm so I mean what way of
incentivizing is there a market you know
mode of operating guys needs more money
but I mean I I agree I'm not gonna turn
down more money and you know ever since
the phoenicians oh no it's very
important that you guys have a guarantee
universal physics income Ralph Ralph
Ralph Connery of the sloan Foundation
said this thing said
the bargain was always that you weren't
going to get super rich as a professor
but you would have the freedom
came from your job and that's how we got
great people when we lost the freedom we
stopped being able to compete
effectively for the top people and so my
version of this is you need the freedom
of a billionaire without the wealth we
have had you know and this is a huge
shift in science funding arguably I mean
the last you know 10 years has been some
of the biggest struggles in my career to
get funding from federal sources and
some of the most successful to get it
from private foundations because I think
there is sort of a freedom that comes
with the private foundation and yeah you
can talk about the fu capital that they
can supply but on the other hand they
also have priorities that may not align
with the priorities of the entire nation
right so so I wonder you know if you're
talking to you know somebody who like
Jim Simon's who's been criticized for
merely pursuing his own intellectual
interest I don't think that's fair it's
like guys working on a cure for autism
you know by what so this is an
all-around fantastic yeah he's a unique
human being the unique human being Jim
Simon's had direct instincts there's
nothing more important in my opinion for
the preservation of humanity than
theoretical physics yeah you think it's
actually culturally Susilo irrelevant to
this survival of a society if so how did
we do without it you know until the
1940s or so nineteen thirty's well I
don't agree with that I mean my feeling
about this is first of all that it's
it's necessary for the survival of
humanity for a couple of different
reasons which have to be pulled apart
the first of which is theoretical
physics is unique in the sense that it's
somehow trains the pure mental facility
and the gritty mental facility to work
together like nothing else we've ever
discovered I'm not saying it's not
impossible to duplicate it again but
even relative to mathematicians who I
could make an argument might even be
smarter in a certain kind of
technical sense the power of the hybrid
vigor of pure cleanliness in pure grit
produce something where we never knew
that the human mind was capable of those
flights as we've seen in theoretical
physics so I really believe that if you
wanted to talk about you know the gym
that trains bodies to be at their peak
well for the mind that's theoretical
physics fundamental physics at bats at
dojo right
it's Ludo Joe and the idea that you get
like I'm gonna say this is the horrible
way if China was smart they and by the
Institute for Advanced Study they just
buy out all those guys they're like what
five eyes were just all of them
unbelievable whatever my issues are and
people are like I understand are you
four-eyed Witten are you against well I
have a complicated relationship he's got
right
if I were China I would pay each of
those guys ten million dollars a year
ever deal and the fact that we wouldn't
bid that up is because we're idiots hmm
right so you want the world's smartest
people copy and at your beck and call
and maybe you call them up once every 25
years it's a bargain
shut up hey it it's their money anyway
their and fathers and grandmothers
created it No
so if you look at it and I agree with
you that if you know physics I broaden
it to experiment because I think the
best experimental physicist Oh should
know the ball most about theory actually
we are encumbered as those gonna get to
that yeah okay go ahead take it away so
CERN is the most optimist but then
they're like high-precision experiments
there's all the amazing stuff doing at
the South Pole there's the fact that
LIGO can pick up these faint there's an
analog in the experimental end of this
which is look at what we've done this is
the the reason that you put computers
you know to their limits engineering
tolerances creativity all of this stuff
is hugely valuable anytime you want to
convert it to something else but people
want to do the sexiest stuff when
they're not being tasked for
the Manhattan Project was an engineering
project it wasn't really theoretical
physics project it did have a positive
effect if you look at the Shelter Island
Conference clearly these guys were not
suffering from the same level of learned
helplessness that Dirac's quantum
electrodynamics had induced before we
normalization taught us how to extract
measurable predictions but in all of
these things the key issue is the first
aspect of why you find theoretical
physics is that you want to know that
you can call up the world's smartest
people whenever you need them to solve
your analytic problems that have grit
and indeterminacy in them and there is
an absolute parallel on the experimental
side the second is is that we learned
just over a hundred years ago that we've
got fundamental limitations on visiting
rights to the universe and I can't stand
to constantly hear that Elon wants to go
to Mars to save the world because the
Mars the moon Titan Enceladus there's
just not enough diversity locally to do
any and so we we may be trapped here it
may be that whatever Einstein figured
out more or less is unhackable and that
even when you move some effective
theories to ultimate theories it can be
that there's nothing new to do but right
now between
1952 and 54 you put the world on notice
that we're gonna blow ourselves up
unless we have enough a wisdom explosion
which we got to get off this rock and
you've got to stop hearing that as
science fiction or somebody who watched
too many you know Star Wars movies it's
only gonna take one device going off in
a mid-level City as a demonstration of
prowess to let people know that you
can't always stop something the
ballistic missile you can't detect all
of the refine rich fissile material
whatever we're in theoretical physics
changed the game with the hydrogen
devices of the early 50s and we are now
in the adaptive valley and we're gonna
dump here at the species if we do not
get out the only group of people can get
us out are either the people who would
upload us into Silicon and forgive me
that sounds completely ridiculous to me
or the people who could find out whether
or not when we pass from effective
Einstein in theory to ultimate theory we
are in fact limited and so mmm so to
actually go mm-hmm so to determine that
right so I wanted to bring this up
actually in a series of rapid-fire
questions at the end where I'm just
gonna ask you to say yes or no if you
have you know greater than 50% credulity
and various items one of them was mine
you're asking in on no I know that Eric
but you're a thinker and and you would
know very much about risk and you know
very well schooled and Bayesian
reasoning and I think I'm just an
internet personality and podcaster noted
podcaster noted noted so you look at the
Drake Equation and it was born right
after you know World War two in 1961
Frank Drake came up with this famous
theory and actually most of the terms in
that equation it's not really an
equation that would satisfy any
mathematician of note nor does it ever
come along with concomitant error error
bars error analyses is always just
multiply these fractions together and
you'll get a likelihood but the one
uncertainty that we haven't revealed in
other words we know star formation rates
of galaxies we know the number of stars
that have habitable zone
planets we don't know L the lifetime and
it sounds to me and we had a
conversation with this last week offline
you know that you are actually very
deeply it's not it's not just you know
kind of a headline you know grabbing
thing that you are very concerned I
don't know if you're a member of the you
know atomic bulletin whatever this Union
of Atomic Scientists bulletin of Atomic
Scientists or if it's respectable I'm
not part of you you would never join
such a such a group that no no I would
never be asked I see okay this one's run
by your friend Lawrence Krauss so I
wonder if it could be liver mentors Pro
okay so so in the Drake Equation in the
letter L stands for the longevity
lifetime of a civilization do you really
believe that that we might be in our
final hour you know thirty seconds to
midnight as this clock is being set
currently I I'd be astounded if we don't
do anything clever that we make it three
hundred years
Wow so your approach and we briefly
touch upon this but I wanted to delve
into it those geometric unity offer a
potential Avenue to you know break the
speed limit to to transgress C as a
fundamental limitation if so it would be
very interesting to Stephen Wolfram
because he's claiming and his competing
you know approach to find a fundamental
theories he has a computing approved
well I'm saying his his theory of the
fundamental physics project is is that
the speed of light emerges from what he
calls branching space which I take to be
essentially a hilbert space like object
that can subdivide a certain rate and
because of that limitation and the
propagation of these networks nodes etc
in branching space the speed of branch
again I'm summarizing it you can watch
my interview with him or watch one of
his many well produced and and
delightful interviews but on the other
hand he believes that he can predict it
it's actually a retro dictum so wouldn't
that stand in Contra distinction to any
help to to actually find that C is it's
just a milestone if you will a speed
limit that is not truly fundamental yeah
I don't understand the question
well a geometric unity can it can can
the speed of light ultimately be derived
as a prediction from GM
Trinity or are you are we sort of hoping
that it might have a it might not be the
fundamental limit I mean you're you seem
you know we're worried about the
lifetime of civilization and we want to
get far away farther away than Saturn
right yeah would you permit me to
rephrase the question slightly yeah
there it works
mm-hmm so first part of it is people
tend to feel better if they can link you
to something by God oh well you're Peter
Till's employee or well you and Stephen
Wolfram have this rival none of this is
right I'm good I'm super glad that
Stephen Wolfram is doing whatever
Stephen willfully yeah is doing it has
almost nothing to do with anything I
know it does okay so just to be clear
I think what your question should be is
first of all how is Einsteinian
space-time recovered from within your
theory given that Newton for example had
to be recovered from Einstein in
low-velocity situation question would be
given the fact that you're not because
because he whenever I say something
about getting off this rock
people map that Oh faster than light and
that assumes that you're still staying
in the space-time paradigm right x4 the
idea is that somehow you broken the
speed limit in the four dimensions with
metric and squeezed in essence the claim
is is that Einstein filleted the metric
bundle in other words one way of looking
at Einstein's theory in a modern context
would be that he took four degrees of
freedom he built the metric bundle on
top of that which would be a point wise
bundle of fibers of dimension ten
because if you take four degrees of
freedom and you take four squared plus
four divided by two that 16 plus four is
twenty divided by two is tens you get
ten degrees of freedom which is why
Einstein field equations occur in sort
of ten coupled differential equations
now that object is only relevant for the
particular space-time metric that
Einstein uses to endow the four degrees
of freedom with this extra structure to
create space-time what if that's the big
error that in fact you should be having
the field
mostly propagate on the fourteen
dimensional space which would be the
four degrees of freedom plus the ten
degrees of rulers and protractors
otherwise known as symmetric non
degenerate two tensors
then the idea is that a particular
choice of einsteinium metric is a
section of that bundle that section can
be used
pull back information from the 14
dimensions down to the four dimension
and then you have this interesting thing
which is maybe not all the fields live
on the 14 maybe some are native to the
for some are native to the 14 but they
all appear to be pulled back on the
floor so that we constantly live in
Plato's cave where we can't see the 14
and we sort of know that this 10 is out
there because then in this ten would
sort of be the same 10 as the spin 10
theory that contains the SU 5 grand
unified theory or more correctly my
guess is is that it lines up with the
petit Salaam theory which is a theory
based on the group su 4 process you to
process you to
now su 4 by lo dimensionalized some
morphisms is oddly spin 6 whereas su 2
process u 2 is another name for a spin 4
so spin 6 cross spin 4 4 plus 10 is 10
again and so you get back to this this
magical number of 10 and I don't think
that I've seen that much identifying
these 10 dimensions that are hidden in
the Petit Salam somewhat more explicit
what you guys call s o 10 which you
should call spin 10 but I don't want a
quibble over terminology that's just
local mocking and then you have this
issue where that actually has geometric
dynamic significance and what we're
looking at is kind of the restriction of
these fields to a filament confusing
fields that are native to the for wood
needed fields that are native to the
induced 14 dimensional structure so
that's how I'm stained fits in to the
observers in the most geometric unity is
broader than this doesn't have to use
the dimetric bundle but in the most
aggressive version of geometric unity
that 10 appears twice and I don't know
that that connection has been much
remark
no I don't think it has is it true that
you basically would have only for me on
like particles in other words spin
intrinsically spin spin oriole operators
or spinners that that would then compose
both the the particles and massive
particles and also their mediators no no
no you would have see one of the key
problems which I can't seem to get any
physicists to care about is it when you
have everybody scurrying around saying
that they want to quantize gravity which
is sort of weird it's a weird
replacement right we used to want
unified field theories and then somebody
subtly said oh holy grail is quantized
and grabbed an incredible sleight of
hand greatest taste if you want to
quantize gravity my key question to you
is always about the electron as opposed
to the photon is a spin one particle
would be a perturbation in a bundle that
will exist whether or not a metric is
chosen so if you imagine that you have a
period of time when there is no metric
between observations whatever that the
ocean in which the photon is a wave
still is well-defined but the wave may
not be known what happens when you don't
have a metric and you look at the
electron ocean well then there's no
ocean in other words that there's a
different feature with fractional spin
which you're gonna call fermions or
matter well which is that finite
dimensional matter is not defined for
what would be called
GL for R double cover so you have a
flabby symmetry group and you only get
the the ocean of electron
once you take the flab out of it and
make it rigid so if you want to quantize
gravity I always want to know I
understand sort of what you might need
in a world of photons only but if the
fermions in your world I have no idea
what you're talking about when you want
a quantized gravity between observation
as it's one thing not to know where the
babes are it's another thing to misplace
the Pacific between every you know every
moment you don't have rulers and
protract
this is a big problem and one of the
things geometric unity does is it finds
a spinner bundle that does not depend on
metric it just can't live or dimensional
space it's forced into the 14th and it's
not the honest spinner bundle that you
would associate with the tangible it's
very closely related something called
the Chimera tangent bond which leads
America spinners upstairs in the 14
dimensional world you're interested in
both bosons and fermions in fact you're
just a super group structure and that
object upstairs pulls back to what we
seem to perceive like as far as I'm
concerned I think we're having a 14
dimensional conversation I'm usually
accused of being one-dimensional not
having a 14 dimensional conversation
we're taking a four-dimensional filament
of it and you know maybe that's what
Sean Carroll is talking about when he's
going on about how he believes
wholeheartedly in the multiverse 50% of
them anyway 50% of them doesn't I don't
know but I just think that in general
what happened is is that if around the
time the unified field theory gave way
to quantizing gravity nobody noticed the
slide and nobody noticed the real
conceptual problems he and that you've
got generations of people repeating what
their more recent ancestors said that
would have shocked I think a lot of the
guys who actually built this stuff from
the early 20th century
you've mentioned are are we off of this
topic for now Eric are you on a word I
don't know I mean it's your podcast if
you want to talk yeah I'd like to talk
physics I'd like to talk about you know
because again I use simple-minded I like
to use everything treat everything like
a nail and my hammer is looking at
things through experimental lenses
before we do that we briefly touched up
in popper and we briefly touched on
girdle
and I had this conversation with Stephen
Wolfram and I've had it with with other
thinkers ranging from Freeman Dyson to
Roger Penrose and and Jim Gates and I'd
like to know your take on this
I believe that physicists are suffering
from math Envy you know in Freudian
language replacing certain protuberance
with with the word math and that's in a
sense that girdle at least showed them
the limits of what was possible in
mathematics or impossible the so called
incompleteness theorem and for decades
or maybe not it's been taken as sort of
sacrosanct at a level which I believe is
unearned that popper provided an
analogue for physicists for a theory for
ways to determine the the credulity one
should have in a physical theory and
that was whether or not it could be
falsified and falsification has come to
mean not just evidence but or evidence
against but even you know the ability to
retro dict certain certain things that
are known to be subsumed within the
theoretical or physical theory I'm
wondering what what D what would you or
do you believe in poppers
you know dialectic or do you believe you
know in his in his demarcation claim or
is there something superior in your mind
that could replace it and then obviously
I want to turn that to geometric unity
so first what do you think about the
girdle popper you know distinction that
I'm making here these are these are
these beautiful hopes that we're going
to be able to codify what science is
what science isn't I think important
that we say why we're animated by this
mm-hmm trying to get rid of cranks and
losers and freaks and we're to distract
us and figure out what the magic formula
is that we can do science pie so that we
can say look we're an open community we
can we welcome everyone wants to try to
pull the sword out of the stone and in
fact you guys broke the rules so you
guys don't get to try anymore and the
people who are playing by the rules good
kids and the other ones get along folder
stock right so that's what our
motivation is because frankly we don't
want a huge line of incompetence trying
their hand you know it takes days to
debunk somebody who's filled with
and there's always 12 more behind that
purse so I think it's really much better
to talk about the political economy of
this and talk about the opportunity cost
debunk well it's very expensive to talk
about what I find ridiculous is when
people treat somebody like me like that
because they're looking for a
demarcation solution which is it's just
very silly but the locals sometimes want
to play that game in general I haven't
found that many people want to play with
me but let's keep going I think that
we're in some very different place with
popper and what I've said before is that
the scientific method is actually the
radio edit of great science so I mean
something very particular by that great
science is whatever people have done to
make major advances and then whatever
people might do make major advances I
remember hanging out with Jim Watson
where he more or less said that rosalind
Franklin was a much better scientist
than he was but his point was that we
were great scientists and she was very
very good but we were not very very good
not just the great is better than good
it's two different styles I want to look
at a really revolutionary essay he wrote
something like you know succeeding in
science rules of thumb or something like
that the style of great science is in
general in defensive if you looked at in
my opinion sort of the three great names
of 20th century physics and I'm gonna
I'm gonna come up with a list other
people aren't gonna love they're gonna
agree with me on Einstein and Dirac and
then weirdly Frank yang cn yang gets
left off because people want to say
Weinberg Fineman something like that I
find that very weird I think yang is way
up there but those guys are the ones
with their names on the laws of nature
and if you look to what they say they're
all talking about beauty so well they're
notwithstanding if the problem is have
beauty as a method there is the beauty
method in science and it almost never
works except for our very best people so
if you look right
the top of theoretical physics
everyone's talking about beauty but it's
like three guys you know and what do you
do with a method that's you know a
little bit like you know what was it the
the Blackbird aircraft that almost no
one can fly but it's the highest
performance you know airplane in the sky
well that's what the beauty method is
it's not about copper it's not about
falsifications by intuition but guts
yeah all the things that you you want to
tell if your average person do not use
this well it will cause you to crash
into the rocks
so trying to give advice for good
science and advice for great science is
very frustrating is it's not the same
thing
in general great science look like bad
science that happens to work and well
you know it's like okay could kick Uli
is thinking about a snake eating itself
and it turns out to be benzene you know
how are you gonna recommend people do
that there's an old joke or something
about that we don't use the Fineman
method in this class what's the Fineman
method you look the problem you think
you're hard you write down the answer
we have to recognize that in general
there isn't a scientific method there's
something that we can clean up and show
to try to say that what we're doing is
defensible and that we're not talking
mumbo-jumbo but I'm going to tell you
the horrible dirty secret at the bottom
of all of this it's about taste and
everyone knows it
they're not you give you know who is it
I guess it was Murray gell-mann who gave
Swartz a job at Caltech because he had
the sense that this guy's working on
something important whether I'm a string
theorist a theory booster or not is not
really the important point you know
shorts Gelman was right and you have
this problem that at the bottom of all
this is not something that is sanitized
that can be cleaned up to show your
parents this is a terrifying marginal
bizarre activity and this is part of why
you get people who are so angry about
people breaking the rules because
honestly those aren't the rules peer
review is not really long for from
Brooke has not been long in our world
this is about personal communications if
you look at what happened with with
Freeman Dyson trying to defend Fineman
to Oppenheimer and having to call in
Veda and then you know Oppenheimer
puts this note in his inbox nolo
contendere and the guy had a job the
Institute for Advanced Study with no PhD
in either math or physics for the rest
of his life this is how badasses get
[ __ ] done is is that it's about knowing
people so intimately and trusting people
so intimately and having enough
resources that you can run something
like the RNAi tide Club and share hurly
results knowing that everybody is good
enough to get their own goddamn Nobel
Prize and if they don't get Nobel Prize
everybody knows it anyway we don't
really need this internally nobody
nobody's confused about stock alberto
outside of the people inside the
community we all know that he was super
important he got shafted so it's very
important to recognize this is a small
intimate activity of weirdos freaks
madmen it's a circus and the adorable
focus on the demarcation problem that
comes from history and sociology of
science programs is very touching and
sweet but they should get the hell out
of our fields and let us get down to
work and do what we do best which is
breaking rules and doing any
things been known ever I'm doing ants
but of course there's the you know
greater possible abstract space of
possibly true theories or possibly true
laws of nature than actually true and I
think what you care about you know
Einstein famously said imagination is
more important than knowledge but as I
said I was talking to Sascha Segan Carl
Sagan's daughter yesterday on the
podcast and you know here's her father's
doll of her father and and we're saying
you know imagination is great and it's
wonderful to have it and we should
cultivate it obviously arthur c clarke
center for human imagination but I don't
want my neurosurgeon god forbid you know
to be allowed to be really creative you
know and curious about you know Brian's
brain surgery god forbid you know I
wanted to have a lot of knowledge or her
to have a lot of knowledge and in the
case of you know these theories you know
who decides that's wrong who did well
you so you would like to have a creative
approach to you know things that have a
true yes sir and I'm arguing Dirac
would've been Dirac he said it's more
important your equations be beautiful
than that they be right or something to
that importance have beauty in one's
equations than if they fit experiment
yeah and so it sounds like you agree
with that and I'm saying the ultimate
Dirac didn't become direct until we
discovered the truth of his derive the
direct equation of the existence of
which he was wrong about originally
identifying the positive I'm not
faulting him obviously he went on to a
good career despite with Bryan Keating
might think about it but but the point
is it is the arbiter it's I might be
arguing my own book but but I'm arguing
that we need experiment to to validate
and maybe that's the ultimate gatekeeper
in your language okay so so so explain
though this this is the problem that
were weak and and this is physics bowing
down to history and sociology of science
the key point was why did Einstein know
what he was doing when I Steinem
Grossman appeared I think in 1913 which
is vaguely said the answer is something
like a linear expression in the Riemann
curvature tensor equal to the stress
energy not specifying what was then he
gets it wrong and he says it's the Ricci
tensor right distilled
and that was show not to be get what
they operator you guys call it
perpendicular to the orbits covariantly
not covalently constant but divergence
three maybe you call it divergence so
then he puts in the one-half scalar
curvature correction to ya and that's
not enough because of Hubble so then he
put in cosmological and then Hilbert
finds okay you're super complicated
equation is actually the simplest Euler
Lagrange equation that comes from the
simplest action you know it's like okay
what how did he know ahead of time that
he was on the right path he kept
correcting it and then this whole thing
about the electron versus the positron
no druk wasn't wrong he was
insufficiently courageous and you know
this is exactly where I'm going through
which is like when you have detractors
you're constantly trying to placate your
detractors oh no really say that didn't
mean that oh please please [ __ ] it's
just stupid the issue is if you'd let
him say okay yeah I don't I don't have
the answer for that if you stop pushing
for agreement
stop pushing for immediate agreement
with experiment I mean this is the
difference between authors and copy
editors the copy editors have taken over
at some levels you've got the lunatics
promoting the string theoretic agenda
which has completely failed that they
can't be ant
they can't be honest about and then
you've got the copy editors which is
like you didn't say Simon Says it's like
shut up
enough it's something in between it's a
very fine Sensibility and it has to do
with a tiny number of people the thing
is intrinsically elitist because taste
is what you're using before you get to
the ability to agree with the experiment
is the question that in the end it has
to agree with experiment of course but
like that's some super late stage thing
and again oh yeah same privileges the
tailor as if the tailor made the suit
but I got to agree with the experiment
he put the last dot on the last time
really I mean are you that soulless that
you can't actually recognize that
Hilbert was not in a race with Einstein
I think if you look at it and you see
you know you see the prestige levels and
I'm not you know one for going through
the sociology of science anymore then I
believe you are but you look at the
prestige afforded to physicists and you
know it goes it goes as you said it'll
go you know Einstein in this the last
you know 150 years you know Bohr it'll
go to fine men it'll go if it makes it
to someone who did an experiment it'll
be Fermi and you know we can argue and
debate it whether or not he was so I
think you're certainly right the
prestige goes to it and I think the time
I can't shut up about matter whew yeah
right you look at that and then you look
at many of the great discoveries by
quote-unquote experimentalist or non
theorists and you know resulting in
Nobel Prizes or other metrics pick your
favorite one you know our first
serendipitous discoveries that we you
know maybe even the theorists had
discounted but but it's it's usually not
I think Dicky is an exception cuz I
think he was equally fat you know facile
with with his theory and he was a
top-notch experimentalist he's kind of
my hero in that sense and it harkens
back to the Galileo model but you know
that being said if there were ways to
channel to test gee you I mean could
could we speculate as to what they are
because I think I think Eric there are
ways to test it I mean you are talking
about certain things in your in your
lecture and I'm trying to avoid that
yeah I know your void is is that I'm
trying to avoid anything mortality the
infant mortality that would come from oh
this is not worth pursuing because he's
not putting it in a journal and
requiring an experiment I know that's a
high so it's not that it's just I'm
sickened by watching a noble family
forget
it's role in the world right like you
know it's the arrogance without the
accomplishment
you guys haven't figured out you have to
tell the interlopers from outside you
know this is something it's an elitist
activity as much as I hate to say it the
top three guys in the 20th century we're
just different they were different they
were using different methods I might
even in group Fineman and I might talk
about stucco Berg which people aren't
going to necessarily want to hear about
yeah you can't it's not a gala Terry
it's it's not fair it's not a fair
subject and if you want well tell me
tell me what science is and what what it
isn't so that I can apply the rule it's
like okay when you're up it when you're
up this high above the tree line the
world works differently and nobody
there's no reason that an ape should be
able to do these things there's a huge
surprise that this is even possible with
that said my frustration is that this
phobic family has fallen into so much
poverty that it can't behave properly
scientifically and my story about
Oppenheimer and Dyson was it maybe uh
maybe Dyson did need baited to come in
and say hey pay attention to the kid
he's he's got it going on but it got
done it worked out on people did not
lose their livelihoods their jobs they
didn't need ph d--'s like we knew who
was good and it wasn't we gave them time
we gave them space and so you're coming
after me huh the joke's on you I'm not
even mean I'm using none of your
resources at all what are you gonna do
cut off my ops you can't
absolutely can cut off my internet yeah
covered you want to get back to testing
yet the key point is imagine people came
to say instead of hey how do we get rid
of you they said
we're really interested what do you
think you might be telling us we know
you're not a physicist we know that
you're working at a geometric level we
know that it needs to be quantized we
know that you don't understand exactly
how we calculate quantum field theory
Marcus you're terrible pedagogues
what could we do constructively I'd be
all over that well I've got some
suggestions say let me just say
something yeah go ahead
I am Keating professor Bryan Keating is
unusual in that he's been after me for
years to come to UC San Diego and
lecture which is very courageous so I
don't know if I'm courageous but I know
sir that you are I want you to be a
visiting scholar here actually which we
will talk about absolute honor be an
absolute honor what I would say is a
bunch of new particles that I can read
off their properties relative to the
internal symmetry groups so we've got
weak hypercharge we guys it's been
strong internal quantum numbers there
are a huge number of new particles that
are predicted in this theory to exist
now the instant I say the word
prediction I get into a different thing
first of us okay what would happen would
we have seen them you know where would
they be in the in the in the in the
that's within the decay rates bubble
okay so that's that energy whatever I
don't know how to give all that stuff I
can tell you that if it was somebody
else coming up with this theory they'd
say oh well we would think that we
should have seen them that would be like
Dirac saying the antiparticle of the
electron must be the proton because I
don't know of a positively charged
particle of a point the electron because
positron had my understanding stupid
Dirac yeah that's stupid Dirac right but
like if you pressure me oh I don't know
and I'll make the same mistake Dirac
mates and then you can have your
Heisenberg coming out so Eric didn't
know about this let's leave that energy
aside yeah if it was something inside of
the community they might say look I've
got something that fits most everything
and it's off a little bit over here
let's tailor it together well that would
be an invitation to a conversation what
could we do is there a new field that we
might introduce to supress
maybe this is actually
naturally-occurring same point about
Dirac and you know maybe oh you didn't
take into account this aspect of spin
what can I tell you about the theory
first of all I don't think the way you
guys call antimatter is antimatter I
think there's an entirely different
sector that would properly be understood
as antimatter I think there's a 14
dimensional space you guys are applying
these things all in dimension 4 I think
there is spin 3 halves matter that is
actually real I don't think that one of
the three generations is a true
generation I believe that if you amp it
up in terms of energy it will unify with
other particles you've never seen I
believe that probably in gravitationally
weak places what we see is a decoupling
of equations but the near black holes
you might very well see the things that
had been decoupled become coupled and
therefore a lot of stuff might come
surging into interview and so that what
was dark might become light I mean
there's any one of a number of things
that you could read off and what if you
don't mind I don't think that I've had a
single friendly confident inquiry in a
month since I released it well yeah I've
been thinking about it since you
released it and we get we made contact
last week I want to talk to you about
well first of all I want to talk to you
about something you kind of made as an
offhand comment in your April Fool's Day
podcast and I'm sorry to keep calling it
that it's just easier for me no that's
what I tried to do I wanted oh if this
works it's a matte and just dream with
me because I yeah yeah
so that it works yep published on April
Fool's Day right and every year a
pent-up energy of all of these
communities would you'd be able to air
these things without losing your job oh
this is the Weinstein tradition like
what I'm talking about honoring me
imagine that every year we could say
things like I wonder if stress doesn't
cause ulcers
I wonder if grain should be at the base
of the food pyramid
I wonder whether or not the amount of
solution in the literature really works
I wonder if the weak force might be
asymmetric you know right many things
have we been afraid to say like with
kovat I'm positively convinced that
there are doctors who are looking at
this thing no mokou the sense of this
doesn't make sense it doesn't work
something is weirdly off danger the
danger of this is that people are
holding back for fear of being drummed
out of their fields so the whole point
of releasing of April crisp is my
fantasy would be if this were to work
not only getting humans off this planet
but making sure two things one that an
h-index of zero became a respectable
thing saying I choose not to avail
myself of your insane community and its
bizarre ritual because your two narcs
and you're trying to fight the cranks
but lots of us are neither dark nor
crank and every year I want you to know
that you have a day where you're free
yeah same thing like I think David gross
is not leading the theoretical physics
community properly and as brilliant as
Ed Witten I think he's contributed
mmm-hmm and not lose your job yeah I
kind of see it as what's that movie
where they have like one day of the year
they can commit any crime but another
listeners are screaming I mean I'll put
it in the show notes people don't don't
worry but there's a and then unavoidably
if you are yeah it'll be essential to
quote that it was released on April
Fool's Day so I think it's a brilliant
piece of intentional or unimportant on
April Fool's Day I released this by a
few minutes I know I know but I'm just
gonna keep calling it that anyway in
your in your in the podcast you talked
about you know one of the great moments
of of relief for you at least at some
point when you discovered that you know
your theory wouldn't work if neutrinos
were masked
but it did work because we know that
they have masses we don't know what
their masses are and I wonder if you are
aware you probably are but but it's not
absolutely known that the that all three
neutrino species have mass in other
words there's only known to be a mass
difference a mass squared difference to
be technical between two you know the
two different eigen eigen States but we
don't know actually one of them could be
massless with that in some way false if
we discover that one species is massless
and umu one or something like that one
flavor then with that would that be a
falsification opportunity for the popper
really what it really means is it needs
if you think about the su5 theory let's
say grand unified theory there's like a
five and an ant and representation you
can put in an inactive singlet but the
important thing is is that it be sixteen
particles in a generation and so the
issue that I was having it wasn't even
necessarily the case that it wasn't but
there weren't sixteen particle but
people were still very much trying to be
conservative and saying well why decide
if you have what is the de right-handed
neutral truck you know then it's
effectively dark and so the key issue is
just that there be a spin Oriole
representation not really about mass
mmm-hmm so it's easier to say it in
terms of masses and neutrinos but I'm
not trying to hide anything so I'm just
I'll say to them work the more correct
version is it has to come from a sixteen
dimensional representation or rather a
spin Oriole representation to to the N
or you can do it more broadly with the
reader Schwinger but it's a very
restricted class over so that would not
be you know if we are cosmological
experiments like Simon's Observatory and
bicep etcetera are trying to you know in
some level constrain the mass neutrino
the sum of the mass of
neutrinos and then that combined with
reactor experiments might actually
reveal the the absolute masses instead
of just the sum of their squares and
square root is so to speak I'm getting
questions from my from a listener who
wants me to ask you is a distinguished
professor at Brown University and he's
asking me to ask you in real time
he does play the saxophone who does he's
also the president of the National
Society of black physicists which I am a
proud honorary member of and yes it is
Stephon Alexander best friend and best
man at my wedding and Stefan is asking
in real time what is your theory I have
to say about the cosmological constant
problem or about dark matter we sort of
hit on antimatter tell us answer
Stefan's question about the cosmological
constant and or dark matter
first of all I would say that the
cosmological constant would not be a
constant it would be event I mean look
I'm gonna try to speak physics and hang
out please do yeah
if I screw up it's okay you get a pass
try this at home you can put on the
mathematician hat if you make a mistake
well we don't talk like this I would say
that it's a vent and the valve is lured
away from zero because there is a
curvature piece that is pervasive that
as the universe is spread out god I keep
talking like this as the cross-section
three-dimensional space like
cross-section spread out that viv has
gotten very low but it's still nonzero
and that the look let me
way that that you're luring something
away from zero potentially because
you've got a topological contribution
and if you have some sort of Gausman a
theorem then you have to be able to
recover the the topology from the
curvature so you could have a reason
that you couldn't get rid of the
curvature but you could spread it out
and therefore you have counter balance
determine me with respect to dark matter
there's a lot of it part this is the
decoupling so the claim is that the
matter wasn't dark originally in high
gravitational situation but it became
dark and as that went down and
effectively a coupled equation broke
into effectively a coupled equation the
decoupled equations would have things
like dark light dark gluons accion's so
you know there's a ton of there's a ton
to be speculated and you don't know that
it broke the way you're half bro so if
you are in sort of one half of the stuff
and again when I say half I don't
there's stuff that we haven't found in
our half in this theory yeah stuff that
is the couple so so there's like it's
more than half would be dark hmm but you
might be able to say look I don't know
exactly how that the other part broke
mm-hmm but what I would say is you know
that how it would unify the example I
just give to people who are watching um
is if you have a hand you see three
fingers - and for your digits - and for
a pretty symmetric and the middle finger
is symmetric yeah but you could say oh I
wonder if there's a symmetry there where
my index and my ring finger are mirror
images of each other and then you throw
in these two and you say oh shoot Wow
maybe it's spontaneously broken and you
know these things are like weirdly off
but maybe my thumb and my pinky are more
or less the same and then you find out
oh my god it's thumb to thumb not thumb
to pinky and this
stuff is dark because it's decoupled and
so this is all remaining to be found and
this is where the proper antimatter
would be but because you're not even
aware of the 14 dimensional substrate
you're thinking about everything in
four-dimensional terms which is after
it's been pulled back hmm mm-hmm
and so if are we done with that thread
particular answer because I had asked
Devon you the man all right well he's
not listening live unfortunately we
should we should have called him in but
I think we'll do that we're just texting
back and forth sharing pictures of our
daughters today is his daughter's
birthday 12th there's something right
that's right yeah always share a happy
birthday from you I wanted to stick with
mysterious particles and ask you if
they've maybe already been found I want
to quote from an article in not the most
you know necessarily prestigious
scientific journal but Scientific
American no less it's not a
peer-reviewed journal but it's a
discussion of mysterious particles
lurking underground and this is
underground the the great icy continent
that I've been to a couple times called
Antarctica in particular two experiments
that seem to show some concordance and
at least in the moszeter this is Anita
and Ice Cube so Ice Cube I think will be
interesting for you to talk to a nice
actual ice cube scientist and Anna Nita
scientist but they claimed that the
particles that they're finding they
don't have much understanding and I
could technically this is two particles
two events but extremely high
significant statistically speaking we
call 5.8 Sigma and seven Sigma so these
are you know chances of fluke occurrence
to at the hundred thousand two million
one-in-a-million level and if those are
possible certainly you know not seeing
them it would be like the magnetic
monopole problem which was claimed again
on a special date on a holiday to be
discovered at Stanford Blas cabarrus
group the Valentine's Day event where he
claimed back in 1987 I believe that he
detected the magnetic monopole in our
universe and that was later later had to
be reanalyzed and and at least a claim
it wasn't a blunder it was just not a
significant
maxvill has the other one yes that's
right there they're sneaking around
trading between different places on
planet Earth but what do you make about
these particles if is there a way to I
mean so here's an opportunity geometric
unity you know can we say how would
these fit into the geometric unity
framework you invite me to a physics
department I will do you already have an
invitation so we held odd yeah
but this is the issue which is I'm I
lived so far off of your grid that I'm
not going to seminars I'm not discussing
the stuff with people so I don't really
know how to answer that
but I can show you what the
representations are what the equations
are what the lagrangians are in you know
in large measure what holds me up from
this sort of stain is this issue about
the tailoring which is I don't want to
get into a war about the tailor well you
said it's this and actually you forgot a
factor of you know yeah I / - no but no
but I've played with these guys before
and I can't and I don't think you have I
actually have to challenge you there I
don't I think you're painting all
physicists including my brethren and
sistren
in experimental physics with the same
brush that may or may not be justified
okay so great so what I would like is I
would like a full-throated
acknowledgement of work in economics in
gauge Theory from mr. Juan Malthus Anna
it would be my pleasure because I'm a
huge fan of Wands and I'm not a
detractor of Wands that held up as the
credit that should have gone to myself
and p.m. Alana and your wife yes I know
that but I have no control of it I do
have control over no IDs in it I'm just
trying to say you want to talk about the
you know when I submitted certain work
at Harvard for which was peculiar to
dimension eight one of the things was
well if you can't solve the octo neonics
projective plane then it's nothing
and while the authentic projective plane
is dimension 60 so I played various
games of gotcha and Simon Says and what
you're looking at is somebody who
is mature but also is traumatized and
traumatized specifically by the nonsense
of these games so I would love to
participate I would love to play but in
part what it means is I will not be
playing the game like you know people
always love to say Hilbert you know and
eins they were in a race for the
equation they were not if Einstein in
Grossman's first paper was all that we
had and he never put anything else in it
it would still be general relativity
dude Einstein engrossed so I'm gonna
push back on your push back and I'm
saying no the field really has a problem
with credit and attribution that was 116
year 106 years ago but but I will stand
worse since then in theory I can't speak
to that I agree with you in principle
because I have seen nastiness
maybe it's unique to UC San Diego which
has produced such luminaries as your
enemy
dr. Garrett Lisi and he's not my enemy
he's my arch-nemesis arch-nemesis sorry
we love Garrett here and he's a good
friend hopefully come on the podcast
soon as well but cool I want to talk
about you know this notion there is a
difference between let me just get back
okay
yeah would be a great pleasure to see to
have the Aneta experiments translated
from an experimental finding having to
do with things apparently coming through
the surface of the earth yadda yadda
yadda into bundle geometric language and
I can come some of the way towards
experimental but you know I don't know
maybe that requires me being somewhere
for a week in constant dialogue I don't
think I've done that since I've been at
the Perimeter Institute you know I know
almost a decade ago oh yeah we're a
90-minute you know train ride away so
but let me say this I had a conversation
with none other than Sir Roger Penrose
who's been on your podcast and I take it
as somewhat of an inspiration to you as
he is to me and he sat down and he told
me I believe that your bicep results
were correct that you did detect B modes
and they just weren't from inflation you
know he has a theory called the
conformal cyclic cosmological model that
features an inflation 'less you know a
on
system of an cycling back and forth
between different eras Aeons as he calls
them and he pointed out evidence being
you know these so-called Hawking points
that he claims were discovered in our
maps and he pointed to the images that
we produced and the publication held the
great fanfare in 2014 and I stopped them
and I said Roger those are basically you
know PR shots those are those of zero
scientific content within them anything
that you find in it what I would take to
be almost a falsification of your theory
that these exist because these are
highly processed and none of the details
it's just basically like a sketch like
if I if I released an artist sketch of a
criminal it's no more or less you know
credit credible than the you know then
then you know basically a
computer-generated image is just
publicity and he said to me these
wonderful you know words basically like
oh well then I have to reevaluate that
but I you know could it be possible that
this other element magnetic fields
survived not that black holes and and so
it launched a wonderful discussion and
and he's 82 year old guy and he wants to
come here and he and he is coming here
on an annual basis and we talked about
this and he's open to and he's done an
experimentalist and I don't think he's
in the orthodoxy although he's at a
level of renown that you have to take
him seriously and and so again I just
want to say don't tar and feather all
physicists because I think there is
obviously you know I'm friends with
Stefan yeah
I've spoken very highly of Juan of
Edmonton it wouldn't nema are Connie
Hamed David Kaplan the University of
marijuana that's not what the problem
the problem has to do with when
something goes wrong certainly oh yeah
yeah that happens all the time happened
to me when I was a young guy like
there's such a lot it's like being in
Nigeria talking about corruption love
people and like people but it's endemic
to the field and it has to do with there
not being enough resources and not
enough success
my standards are very different like you
know if you imagine that you're a hot
chick in an office in the 1950s you know
and you're getting patted on your on
your ass when you walk down the hallways
and you'll try to imagine a modern woman
having a reaction to that kind of the
culture yes there are all sorts of
things that are normal and supposedly
good people engage in them because the
norms are all shifted well in a world in
which nobody's really apologized for
string theory except for maybe Dan
Frieden at an appropriate level and all
of the you know things that happen as a
result of it the community is in an
unhealthy state I'm not touring all
individuals I'm trying to say that when
this is over we will look back on a lot
of this the way we look back on Jeffery
Chu in the bootstrap this is a very
weird period and for some reason I'm not
under its spell and you know people say
well you know of course everything was
very promising in 1984 with yeast with
the anomaly cancellation well no it
wasn't it wasn't then it wasn't in the
90s with the second string theory lots
of interesting things came out of it but
the point is no it was always nonsense
it was always crazy was always a madness
and it had to do with the fact that
yield hasn't succeeded and that too many
people have concentrated power and the
people who had you know how would how
would you go up against an Ed Witten and
say actually even though you're so
brilliant I still think you're wildly
off and if it grows even though you're
so accomplished I think you're incorrect
these issues or David fuller or Joe
polchinski if you make the argument that
everything is string theory after the
fact well can you imagine putting your
hard work into something that you no
matter what you do they're gonna claim
it and they're telling you ahead of time
all of these things have to do with the
need to clean up the field and I just
want it to be very clear that I am both
its biggest proponent and critic and if
you want to think about it as
Schrodinger's enthusiast that's what I
am
okay well good I know you're super busy
but I can't resist if you'll indulge me
no cuz it's so rare I get to chat with
you and it's so much fun today I got to
tell you I was thrilled and pleased as
punch that you were going to take
neither a booster approached nor let's
throw up let's let's let's teach him a
lesson approach so I want to say that
there's not a lot I what I would want to
put on a jacket for but this was
important okay great well I'll
definitely be be citing that quote on
repeat playing it for my my children and
friends
[Music]
while any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
[Music]